the theater basement was supposed to be
a safe place now potentially hundreds
wait for rescue under the rubble two
days after a russian missile strike
mariupol is a destroyed city but is
being bombarded relentlessly and cut off
from aid
bodies still remain in yards and on the
streets
it's a horror what four tell me what for
what are we guilty of
it's not just in the south where the
attacks are shattering lives
see the missile hit our building
all apartments are totally destroyed i
do not know where i'm going to live now
where i'm going to work
i don't know to carry on living
ukraine's armed forces officials say
russians are trying to increase their
presence around the capital missile
strikes continue to be fired in and
around kiev many are intercepted still
dozens of residential blocks have been
hit
the damage
almost can't be measured life is getting
lost
not just the infrastructure life is
getting lost marijuana
butcher
life is destroyed and taken children are
getting killed
families shared their experiences with
journalists friday all had harrowing
tales of escape
and fear for those left behind there
were those russian tanks and you know i
said if they don't let us through we
prayed god to get through and when we
reached the roadblock their checkpoint
we were stopped and they lined us up and
we looked down because we thought maybe
if they don't like us they will start
shooting us so many right now across the
country are weighing the risks of hiding
versus fleeing and if they get to a new
safer location in ukraine
how long will they have before the
fighting is at their heels once again
crystal gomanson global news
london